en carro con cálido ve madrina del
festival
el destino la universidad de lomé
[Música]
reflexionar pensar hacerse preguntas
sobre el sentido de la ropa en lomé al
margen de la novena edición del film o
el festival internacional de la moda en
todos los universitarios disfrutaron
pero que de la ropa vieja los trapos el
paño podría suscitar el interés de una
doctora en derecho público
por ejemplo
la moda se encuentra en el derecho
constitucional porque es una forma de
expresión de ciertas libertades
fundamentales la libertad de expresión
el hecho por ejemplo de vestirse cuando
por ejemplo se lleva pues una camiseta
en la que hay un mensaje un logo o una
imagen
de su manera de expresar lo moralmente
pero con la muerte la calle doc de es la
madrina del fimo cosecha 2022 jurista
retomó sus estudios en la universidad su
terreno de investigación las apología
plaza
las apología fue usada durante la época
colonial como un instrumento de protesta
frente a la dominación colonial
contestación de la dominación pero
continuó tras las independencias en la
época post colonial
jugando los presidentes mobutu y sassou
nguesso llegaron al poder
y su gobernanza fue considerada
autocrática
este movimiento retomo amplitud e
impulso pero en este caso como un
movimiento una reivindicación de
democracia social
la sape y la sociedad de los generadores
de ambientes festivos y de las personas
elegantes se popularizó en brazzaville y
kinshasa en el congo durante los años 60
este delicado arte se propagó desde
entonces por todo el continente
sabes entre los apólogos tal como
decimos ok se habla del respeto de los
códigos de colores
es decir que cuando se quiere llevar
ropa puesta no se debe exceder más de
tres colores 23 colores máximos pero
cuando se domina el arte de la cosa
usted es libre de alternar porque lo
importante es el resultado final
es la esencia de este festival fuera de
lo común hibridaciones mezclas alianza
de disparidades
yo uso telas europeas para hacer trajes
africanos
áfrica acompañados con accesorios
africanos áfrica
entonces creo que es un mestizaje
la idea es reunir dos modas
las de la oscuridad y la luz el yin y el
yang
fabrice way y 29 años llevo de malí para
presentar su colección la cantv es el
nombre de su marca lo que traducido del
bambara significa dueño de su destino
el objetivo de la nueva generación es
incitar a la población a tener una nueva
educación
a poder consumir producción local es la
policía cuando se habla de inmigración
clandestina el desempleo es el que
obliga a los jóvenes a migrar louis
sumas de kiki puzzles pero con nosotros
somos jóvenes diseñadores
trabajamos con los artesanos
con muchas personas a nuestro alrededor
popular nuestros colaboradores
entonces acudiendo a ellos reducimos el
desempleo y le aportamos a la economía
el compromiso social económico ecológico
ya no es una tendencia es una necesidad
desde hace cerca de dos décadas maurice
jarre ve ha hecho de ello su lucha yo
trabajo a partir de la materia prima
reconozco que es la ropa la que me
inspira y con la práctica que he
desarrollado desde hace 18 años
desarrollo en muchas técnicas
entonces lo que puedo hacer a partir de
así aún haya muchas cosas por descubrir
creativamente en cuanto a la manera de
transformarlo es casi infinito entonces
con el tiempo clasifique las tipologías
de ropa según su transformación un
consenso previo de hecho en el ciclo de
reciclaje de la ropa ya que se regala
hay toneladas de ropa de algodón aceite
que llega de europa áfrica y creo que es
pertinente mostrar una colección apps
icon para que se vea lo que se puede
hacer con ellos
igualmente adopta una moda ética
jennifer ven y viaja entre lagos en
nigeria y lomé donde reside
fui al mercado y encontré ropa que venía
de muchos países sabe pascal y
sólo voy cuando se prestan a quemar toda
esa ropa rasgada manchada
stein encontré cosas de china india
escocia inglaterra inglaterra es por
ello que hace mucho tweets
de nomine mi colección los cinco
destinos la ropa recorre el mundo y
aterriza aquí
con frecuencia he usado los términos
reciclar y transformar pero hoy hoy en
día mi mensaje es diferente se trata de
amar nuestra ropa y para mencionar las
contaminaciones debido a la
proliferación de plásticos unos
estudiantes combinaron rafia y vinilos
transparentes
somos togolesas entonces quisimos
mezclar todo para glorificar la tierra
de nuestros ancestros
una novena edición del festival
internacional de la moda en todo
inteligente moderna convincente en su
deseo de abordar los problemas que
enojan valorizando el trabajo de
diseñadores del continente